[Musique]
bonsoir des petits amis bonsoir ainsi
que nous l'a promis hier soir nous
allons vous raconter une histoire c'est
celle le sait - laurent furent lesur
prusse potro juge suite
vas-y mango north et ne traîne pas trop
qu'on touche aux propres troupes
bon les joueurs pourront pas un beau
livre d'image que je vais vous montrer
et que le traduit le marchand de sable
va vous raconter et c'était l'histoire
asseyons-nous d'abord aux mails vous
bousculez pas comme ça
[Musique]
nous y sommes c'est la belle histoire
dolan chu le petit chihuahua au bout pas
trop voilà ce monsieur seuil en chu
ayant que chu et jardiniers il a un
grand jardin dans lequel il travaille
beaucoup
ils plantent des légumes des fleurs et
des arbres qui donnent des fruits
qu'est-ce que ça à dire dis non c'est
toi qui connais le chinois yang chut
chut ma foi ça veut dire en français
le petit veau qui ne parut pas émis par
un beau matin clair yang chichi parti
pour le marché ils arrosent a d'abord
son jardin des parties il voulait
acheter des noyaux de cerises pour faire
pousser une cerisier 10 90
il est mal à ça petit jules fait tiquer
nicolas mais tout à coup on entendit des
cris déchirants
il vit un joli petit âne qui pleurait et
à un gros vilain bonhomme qui tapaient
dessus avec un fouet jong chul saisi un
bâton et 10 aux gros vilain laisser ce
petit âne tranquille c'est très méchant
de faire ça et pan pan pan
il donna quelques coups de bâton sur la
tête du gros vilain biens divers et gros
vilain demanda pardon pardon an giang
chut chut je ne le ferai plus est il
parti se cacher tout honteux jiangxi
acheta le petit âne et ils l'ont emmené
avec lui dans son jardin le petit âne
était très content et il donna à yang
chu rat pack est de noyaux de cerises
que le petit chinois avait oublié
d'acheter au marché il est plantaire
ensemble dont la terre et ils devinrent
des amis inséparables reims qui les lui
niant mais je préférerais une chéchia
avons le temps l'histoire est terminée
elle vous a plu oui ils étaient très
amis merci petit marchand de sable
mersen annonce à demain
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
juste à la lumière bonne nuit mais
bambins à touba venue n'est qu'à la mode
n'est pas pr neil
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents allaient vite au dodo
et fait doux rêve nouveau la patrouille
allons en route mon gros nounours
bonne nuit à demain
[Musique]
oh